depends from what you think is a luxury
designed for me and all the Italian
design factories phenomenon is a new and
very contemporary form of art and poetry
then his art and poetry luxury i live to
you the question
where the
very much from the era when we were
working in for example in my personal
job done in my work I am dealing with
the objects that are hundreds of years
old if not a millinery solder if you
think how old is a bowl of a cup of a
pot thousand years old that means that
almost all the functional matters have
been have found a solution and the space
which is left is a still space related
to the emotions not so much to the
function you cannot invent so much in my
field